boa tarde a todos antes de mais nada
quero agradecer a oportunidade de estar
realmente pisar este perto do mali foi
sempre um sonho eu sou mariana como
podem ver já tem 21 anos sou estudante
da universidade letras no curso ciências
da comunicação sua universo que ver com
o chakra alinhado daqui um mês ou à
flora
sou do porto e não gosta assim hoje vou
falar sobre a economia sobre a
ambigüidade do ser e não ser que fiquem
descansados que eu não vou cair cita
shakespeare vocês corajosos que envolve
durante alguns minutos
tem que ser um cozinheiro eu adoro
contextualizações eu era aquela aluna
chata
no texto história vou explicar a guerra
mundial quem estava a falar do neolítico
portanto para mim nós tudo tem que ter
uma razão e eu falar nessa razão em
falar na outra razão que levou ainda uma
razão que por sua vez é oriunda de outra
razão e nós enquanto espécie enquanto
seus humanos como é que nossa razão da
invasão para a qual estávamos cá
coloquem nossa explicação
adão e eva nem mais após estavam todos a
pensar em si é sério como é que uma
pessoa vai confiar o paraíso uma senhora
que falava com cobras que sim de uma
coisa sou baiana tem 21 anos e sua
conquista
é verdade
eva tramam nos tirou os pitons do
paraíso da vida perfeita mesma partida
por razão para não dar aquela 30 gramas
é um parentesco cuidam também homem
notável posto no mundo
a primeira mulher comer fruta em prol da
humanidade
eu tenho que fazer
amamos a vida mas de uma forma senão
chegamos do paraíso nós foram lançadas
as pedras
nós temos que começar a fazer tivemos
como desculpa conhecer outras vezes
temos que ser outra vez o mundo
trabalhamos a vida portugal criam um
levantou
estou vindo com uma situação ficou é que
vocês não tem noção
nós temos que fazer à vida que devemos
fazer e é isso que eu vou falar o que
fazer
acho que fazer a minha palavra favorita
sendo muito nesta fazer a minha palavra
favorita
eu acredito que tem muita coisa então a
gente começa a pensar assim fixo foi
assim na minha com o propósito de não
estarmos ficar no planeta terra e fazer
nós estamos cá para fazer é criar um
momento para fazer o momento
vou fazer por nós fazer com os outros
fazer e agora vocês perguntou assim ou
talvez não
será que nós estamos a fazer o
suficiente a dizer uma coisa não estava
sempre que durante esta minha posição
sempre que eu falar que estou a falar em
nome da nossa espécie enquanto seres
humanos
eu acho que esta tomar esta temática
fazer fazer mais o que nós podia o que
nós podemos fazer ao longo da nossa vida
desde o momento em que nós tínhamos até
o momento em que vamos selar pra onde eu
vou falar sempre em sessões futuras em
dadas orientações sexuais
é tudo o que nós temos que analisar
sempre mais
agora ninguém faz da sócio forma alguma
a nós já fizemos coisas absolutamente
incríveis incríveis
fomos à lua e até agora tentam falar
vamos à lua ou um caso português
conquistando juntado mundo não na parte
daquilo conquistar mas fomos os
primeiros a alcançar os primeiros a
descobrir grande
o planeta o ser humano já fez coisas
absolutamente incríveis mas é pouco
nós ficamos muito na nossa tenha certeza
quantas vezes vocês e agora fala que
esperar até a próxima jornada porque é
coisa de momento com amigos deixa assim
ah e tal vamos sair a não posso superar
o pato superocupado vocês tão bem gené
cana é ver uma série e simplesmente não
conseguia fazer e ter com o vosso amigo
e ver um filme e ver um café nos
aconteceu
o nosso grande problema é que nós a
nossa pretensão do futuro é muito muito
muito errada totalmente é para nós o
futuro é simplesmente um prolongamento
presente momento em que vocês começam a
entrar em são paulo foi mortal
o futuro é completamente o planeamento
do presente
o que nós temos agora nós vamos sempre
temos de ter a manhã e agora com toda a
legitimidade você pergunta a marina mas
que raio é que tu fizeste toda a vida eu
fui de erasmus para antônia comia trecho
está lá em cima
ou seja quem já foi liberado ontem três
pessoas estas três pessoas que estão
aqui não vão deixar mentir
você achava que aquela ideia é um
conceito gerar os gols todos vocês têm
na cabeça
é verdade é mesmo verdade quando eu
cheguei por cinco momentos maravilhosos
doutor neste evento ainda não tô nem aí
e assim conhecer muito pequenina lei vai
agradar como sendo que uma parte um
aparte o aparte com crianças aqui um
parêntesis eu vivia num dueto russo
treinou à experiência muito mais
aliciantes quando eles ainda achava que
estava em viagem
não só porque conheci pessoas incríveis
ter aprendido muito por ter viajado
muito por entender que este ser um
europeu mas claro causa da festa então
tudo sei e achava que vira todas as
festas e não sei como é que caiu em
lisboa mas lá no porto no início do ano
mestre sempre semana de semana de semana
as festas então foi uma festa na manhã
seguinte estava eu tomar um duche assim
nova recuperação quando eu pensar em um
centro de tudo gratuito para crianças
realmente não podem pagar o
financiamento de qualquer um é só o
estudo não é só de todos nós temos que
ficar é um centro de estudos quando os
anos dará oportunidade para as crianças
conhecerem pra conhecer em um mundo
a vai-vai outra festa e eu falei quando
as minhas amigas com beatriz que o
joanico sara essa linha estava incrível
e elas disseram que sim
chamamos mais amigos e assim nasceu o
jardim público - em cachorro sai assim
nessa chuva e assim mas já te explico
somos uma seleção juvenil com cerca de
80 voluntários da união das várias
universidades do porto e de pensões a
mais de 20 crianças
as crianças são no quinto ou noé e para
ainda dar muitas explicações a todas as
disciplinas todas as dificuldades que
estiverem em nível é o quarto mais pelo
nacional na escola proporcionamos
atividade extra-curricular atue e dança
teatro música pintura debates porque nós
queremos que a educação não é algo que
só foco no que é ensinado na escola mas
que também passa para além disso nós já
expliquei que vamos fazer
queremos que seja um espaço onde as
crianças possam ser mais e possam ser
melhor ou não haja qualquer um entrava
vamos os pequenos a pensar em grandes
que já fazemos há um ano
agora pergunto eu tenho certeza pergunta
você já que nessas idéias já tiveram
imensas ideias em meus projetos
foi o momento com medo nada estava a
tomar vai inflamar deus
eu tenho certeza que vocês já tiveram
imensas ideias e as imensas epifanias
que pensaram não vai resultar como é que
eu fazia
vai ser difícil vai vai ver pessoas a
dizer ah e tal não vai conseguir nem foi
realista
vai é verdade mas é uma sad tem e também
disseram muitas vezes a minha equipa
quando às vezes a ser de estágio ou
saída popular chegou ao jardim público
eu consegui eu posso três anos e
conseguirá positiva na temática
todo o trabalho todo o esforço vale a
pena portanto é fácil e tem que
concretizar a idéia é ainda mais fácil é
muito batata é tão fácil para tanto nas
nossas mãos para tudo porque agora vou
falar muito mais cheio desta exposição
tona no momento em que estou a falar num
momento mais chery que eu acho que nós
somos animais se alimentam se lógica
antropólogo e nós somos animais e da
casa dos segredos o cotel e late show é
schaars hoje nem mais com as finais
nacionais em mais duas finais fixá los e
por uma câmera e transmitem pra outros
animais
aqui ó pai tomaz câmeras web mais firme
estamos a ver em directo fechar a porta
e 33 dias e fazer um forma com que eu
ganhasse era tv a campanha dela é
portanto em uma bola na área
é uma coisa tão básica - como é que uma
pessoa que vê essa ideia de entrar valor
nenhum os parceiros na bahia quem tenha
mais perto foi mesmo foi rápido não sei
se está em lisboa outro utilizando essa
inscrição será até ser assim
e conseguiu já milhões portanto tenho
certeza que em todos vocês e pelo
designados de vocês a uma idéia um
projeto mas isto fazer a pessoa ver com
a funcionar com o trabalho com
voluntariar não teve com conexão com
sair com sempre tira a namorar com tudo
e fazer o nosso plano ser humano é que
nós achamos membro em salt pa
mesmo preguiçoso vamos com um desafio
tão procurados durante um dia vamos
todos dizer que sim que vamos todos
viajar até a indonésia é assim que vamos
fazer é ver um pouco sim acontecer é que
vamos fazer nada conta
não gente não tá vamos dizer sim mas não
sem um comentário não quer ser
responsável por ano sofrimentos mas por
favor tenham mais chinen com inveja em
qualquer lugar que tenham estúpida e uma
coisa eu tenho o que ele chama de
segurança pra aquela imagem está no no
telemóvel é mais meu deus
o prazo mais falar oma avião encontrar
no instagram que a ciência brasileira
não acredita
é isso não tenho medo e não teme pelo
título
os institutos mas nós temos que fazer
mais
chegava no outro dia postou no facebook
não sei se vocês viram no facebook não
tem no entanto mesmo chega para tudo
isso no outro rené o tempo isso assim
ser jovem não ser revolucionário é uma
contradição
tanto juntos vamos fazer uma promessa
juntos vamos fazer mais vamos cherto
vamos projetar vamos decidir mais por
pior que uma decisão e acho pior cuba
mas precisam e não se lhe pode acontecer
falhar
só entrava o pior pode acontecer e nós
morreremos batemos assim ó não tinha e
não temos realizados e pensarmos que eu
tive que fazer
no início da minha apresentação disse
que não está a apresentação isso que não
hesita shakespeare mas valeu a pena
assim eu não sou ramo é como podem
verificar não tenho uma carreira mas que
não quer que o senhor de volta ao caixão
da nossa assinar obra
ou terá sido uma causa
se não serve exatidão ser a mais nova e
não espíritos sofrer pedras e flechas
com que a fortuna oferecida nos avaí já
o em surgir nos quanto o mar de
provocações em luta por fim morrer
dormir não mais entre ser e não ser que
foram sempre ser obrigado a eva
obrigadão e obrigado a todos vós